sons of the forest is one of the hottest
new games out right now currently
topping steam's best seller list at the
time of this recording and having over
200 000 concurrent players on the
platform on its launch day here's
everything you need to know about the
popular new survival title
sons of the forest is a sequel to the
survival game the forest which initially
launched in 2014 in Early Access before
its full release in 2018 the game
features a new story and characters and
while it doesn't take place in the same
Locale the heavily forested Island that
serves as its setting is similar to that
of the first game and was teased at the
end of that title as site 2 in one of
the games two alternate endings in Sons
of the forest you play as an operative
scent to the islands to find Edward
Pufton and his family puffton is the CEO
of puffin Industries which made him uber
wealthy taking his vast fortune and
spending it on Priceless artifacts one
of those artifacts is called the Golden
Cube which puffed and became obsessed
with and discovered was linked somehow
to the site 2 Peninsula after purchasing
the group of islands puffed and began to
build Resort on it but has since failed
to contact the outside world in the
opening moments of the game your
character's helicopter is shot out of
the sky and crash lands on the island
only yourself and fellow operative
Kelvin having survived
the site of the helicopter crash has the
possibility of being one of three
locations on the island the forest the
mountains or the beach your companion
Kelvin has been rendered to death and
mute by the incident and therefore must
be communicated with via handwritten
notes like many other Survival Games
sons of the forest has crafting building
cooking and many other system Staples of
the genre Kelvin can be instructed to
help with the various activities
automating menial tasks that the player
would otherwise have to deal with
players will need to maintain aspects
such as their hunger and thirst as well
in line with other survival games one of
the biggest ways sons of the forest
differs from other Survival Games is
with new AI developer end night has
created to manage non-playable
characters a group of mutant cannibals
reside on the island serving as the
game's primary antagonists the player's
choices such as where this setup camp
and what resources they harvest will
alter the ecosystem and therefore alter
the behaviors of the cannibals to face
them the player will be able to not only
craft and utilize melee weapons but guns
will also be more prevalent than in the
first game that being said ammo in
classic Survival game fashion will be
scarce and therefore players will want
to rely on melee as often as they can
get away with it to alleviate some of
the difficulty of not only having to
maintain shelter hunger and thirst but
to also face off against a group of
cannibals players can team up with
others online with up to 8 players
allowed in a single instance working
together to not only survive but to
uncover the mysteries of the island and
find out what happened to Pufton and his
family
sons of the forest is currently
available in Early Access on Steam for
thirty dollars it is important to note
that the game was initially supposed to
be a full release with end night only
pivoting to Early Access mere weeks
before launch that means players should
expect there to be some rough edges in
the early weeks and months but Steam
Reviews of the game currently give it a
very positive rating with nearly 30 000
reviews marked as such the first game
was in Early Access for four years so
there is the potential that Suns at the
forest's Early Access period could last
as long there is no word currently on a
console Port but the forest was
initially a PC exclusive when it was in
Early Access before coming to
Playstation 4 with the full release so
there is potential for its sequel to do
something similar
that's everything you need to know about
sons of the forest have fun uncovering
the mysteries of sight 2 and make sure
to be subbed to Gamespot for more videos
on the game